>>> THIS MORNING ON "THE DISH,"
A JOURNEY TO THE FABLED CITY OF
VENICE FOR A FEAST ABOARD A
SAILBOAT THAT'S THE LAST OF ITS
KIND.
CHEF AND CAPTAIN MAURO STOPPA
PREPARES EXQUISITE DISHES FOR
PASSENGERS THAT TAKE THEIR
INSPIRATION AND INGREDIENTS FROM
THE SURROUNDING WETLANDS AND
ISLANDS.
CHRIS LIVESAY TAKES US ALONG ON
THIS CULINARY ADVENTURE.
>> Reporter: VENICE AS TRUMAN
CAPOTE ONCE SAID IS LIKE EATING
AN ENTIRE BOX OF CHOCOLATE
LIQUEURS IN ONE GO.
A SUGAR RUSH FOR THE MILLIONS
WHO DEVOUR ITS BEAUTY AND ITS
FOOD WITHOUT STOPPING TO SMELL
THE ROSES.
WHICH IS WHY MAURO STOPPA, ONE
PART SAILOR, ONE PART CULINARY
EVANGELIST, IS ON A QUEST TO
PREACH THE CUISINE OF VENICE BY
LEAVING VENICE.
THAT PIRATE SHIP WITH THE CUDDLY
CREW AND CRIMSON SAILS IS
ACTUALLY HIS ESCAPE POD, A LAST
OF ITS KIND FLAT-BOTTOM SAILBOAT
TRANSFORMED INTO FINE DINING.
CUSTOMIZED FOR FIVE-COURSE MEALS
AS IT GLIDES VISITORS FAR BEYOND
THE GONDOLAS AND DEEP DEEP THE
VENETIAN LAGOON.
AND WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE LAGOON
THAT YOU LOVE SO MUCH?
>> THE QUIET OF THE LAGOON.
YOU MUST BE RELAXED IF YOU ARE
STAYING HERE.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO BE IN A
HURRY.
>> Reporter: IT'S HOME TO 200
SQUARE MILES OF PLACID WETLAND,
THE LARGEST IN EUROPE WITH MORE
THAN 100 ISLANDS, SOME STRAIGHT
OUT OF A COLORING BOOK.
OTHERS BEARING SUNKEN RUINS FROM
ANCIENT ROME IN THE MIDDLE AGES.
THE LAGOON IS ALSO A FERTILE
BREEDING GROUND FOR FISH.
AND NO ONE GETS IT FRESHER THAN
MAURO.
HE EVEN GROWS THE HERBS AND
VEGETABLES HIMSELF ON THE ISLAND
WHERE HE DOCKS HIS BOAT.
WHILE HE MAY LOOK LIKE CHEF
BOYARDEE, YOU WON'T FIND
ANYTHING OUT OF A CAN.
IT'S ALL FROM RIGHT HERE IN THE
LAGOON.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS -- THE WAY I TRY TO WORK,
MAKING WHAT IS POSSIBLE TO HAVE
FROM VEGETABLES AND FISH FROM
THE LAGOON.
>> Reporter: TODAY THAT MEANS
WILD SEABRING WITH EXTRA VIRGIN
OLIVE OIL AND LIME.
THIS IS LIKE VENETIAN SUSHI.
>> MORE OR LESS.
>> Reporter: THEN RAW KUTDS FISH
IN LEMON JUICE WITH MUSHROOMS,
EGGPLANT NEST WITH SAUTEED
SHRIMP, WILD SEA BASS WITH SWEET
POTATO AND PEARS, EVEN THE WINE
IS TINGED WITH THE ADRIATIC.
>> THIS IS GROWING IN -- THE
HILL FACING THE SEA.
SO IT IS SALT.
>> Reporter: AND NOTHING, NOT
EVEN THE GARNISH, IS FOR SHOW.
>> THIS HERBS IS -- IS CALLED
WILD FENNEL.
IT IS GROWING ON THE DRY AREA OF
THE LAGOON, AND IT IS FULL C
VITAMIN --
>> VITAMIN C.
>> YES.
FULL OF TASTE.
SOMETHING NOT IN USE, BUT IN THE
PAST IT WAS VERY, VERY COMMON.
>> Reporter: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK.
ITALIAN FOOD AS BEING MEATY AND
CHEESY AND CARB-Y WITH PASTA,
LASAGNA.
THERE'S NONE OF THAT HERE.
THE INGREDIENTS ARE SO SIMPLE,
BUT THE TASTE, THE FLAVOR IS
EXTREMELY RICH.
>> IF YOU HAVE GOOD INGREDIENTS,
THERE'S -- THERE'S --
>> ALL YOU NEED.
>> IF YOU HAVE BAD INGREDIENTS,
YOU HAVE TO CREATE SOMETHING TO
DISTRACT THEM.
>> Reporter: TO COVER IT UP.
YEAH.
HE'S A QUICK SODIC MISSION
CARRYING ON THE TRADITIONS AND
FOOD OF VENICE AS THE CITY
QUICKLY FORGETS THEM.
LUIGI DIVARI, THE FISHERMAN WHO
CAUGHT OUR LUNCH, IS ONE OF A
DYING BREED HE SAYS.
TODAY THERE ARE ONLY SEVEN FISH
STANDS LEFT NO,AT THE MARKET IN
VENICE.
AS A BOY THERE WERE 28.
SOON IT WILL HAVE TO SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE ALL OF THE VENDORS ARE
ABOUT TO RETIRE.
WHICH IS WHAT MAKES MAURO AND
HIS BOAT SO PRECIOUS.
A FLOATING TIME CAPSULE THAT
NEVER FORGETS DESSERT.
TODAY IT'S THE LAST FIGS OF THE
SEASON.
>> WE HAVE USED THE LIME, ORANGE
JUICE, AND -- AND THE SKIN OF
THE ORANGE.
>> Reporter: OKAY.
GREAT.
SHOULD I JUST POP THE WHOLE
THING IN MY MOUTH?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: OKAY.
>> NICE?
I'M HAPPY.
>> Reporter: IF YOU WERE TO TAKE
THIS MEAL AND TRANSPORT IT
INSIDE A RESTAURANT IN VENICE OR
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD, YOU
WOULDN'T GET THE SAME
EXPERIENCE.
>> NO, NO.
IT IS THE LAGOON THAT OFFERED
THIS -- REALLY AN INGREDIENT OF
THE EXPERIENCE.
VIVA.
>> Reporter: TO THE ALTHOUGH
LAGOON.
>> AND THIS BEAUTIFUL DAY.
>> Reporter: A BASIC INGREDIENT
FOR A GOOD PLEA DEAL AND A --
GOOD MEAL AND A WAY OF LIFE.
FOR "CBS SATURDAY MORNING,"
CHRIS LIVESAY, VENICE.
>> IT LOOKS HORRIBLE.
I MEAN, IT'S NOT SCENIC AT ALL.
THE FOOD LOOKS BAD.
I MEAN --
>> THOSE DOGS ARE LIVING THEIR
BES LIFE.
>> THE -- BAXTER.
LOOKED LIKE HIM.
RIGHT?
>> GORGEOUS DOG.
GORGEOUS PLACE.
>> IS THERE ANY SUCH THING AS
SOMEONE HAVING A MOMENT ON "THE
DISH" WHERE THEY'RE LIKE,